we have this story let's just go for it
here we go everybody
the pod people the new york post says
high school band
uses individual tents to keep practicing
during pandemic
it's a bunch of students standing in
these are i think are like these are not
tense there's something else they're
calling them tents but they're like
personalized garbages garbage they're
upright
fabric they are fabric they're up you
ever get one of those like laundry
hampers
made of wire and it like pops into place
imagine that but big
and you're standing in it these people
died playing the trombone
do this uncomfortably i saw it like
standing standing at a weird
wedged in there this is crazy to me that
people are are doing this stuff
and it was funny because uh as i
mentioned this often i i learned from
the best michael malus on how to
properly tweet
you you tweet in ways where you leave it
ambiguous enough to where
it can be interpretable but you still
express you're either disdain or support
and i said if people are doing this you
know this is you're insane
but you know what at this point i don't
care what you do do whatever you want
i'm gonna go over there in the middle of
the woods
and i'm gonna you know get a little i
gotta i got a bow and arrow we're
getting chickens
yes i kept saying this you know what i'm
gonna go buy chickens i tweeted
and then i bought some chicken coops you
know we'll get some chickens
and i look at the stuff it was funny
when i had a bunch of people say like
you're so dumb tim do you think the
students should spit on each other and
i'm like
they should not go to school if it's
seriously that bad
don't put them in this ridiculous this
is aw this is so ridiculous i gotta say
i
hear this and i think god thank god
some kids get to go to school right
because in we don't have school in
california right now yeah yeah
but i understand that too but it's also
you don't need to do this like you're
you're spitting into a device and you're
standing far away from someone else
this makes no sense can we pull up the
picture of the kid with the trombone
because he is extremely uncomfortable
and imagine
imagine hi and he's also a bigger guy
but but
imagine paying the state to treat your
children like this this is absolutely
absurd and we wonder why kids have a
mental health crisis
this is a part of the reason wired
actually had a very good article today
that i was reading and it's titled
it's ridiculous to treat school
children um like covet hot zones
and they pretty much came to the
conclusion that it's not and that this
is all
pandemic theater and i absolutely agreed
with them because there's a lot of
preliminary science and statistics and
reports showing how there's
absolutely very little threat of covid
in schools and children
transmit the virus very differently than
adults do
this this is this is from last year
though this is from last may yeah but
still it's
but it has been true that children don't
spread i mean let's
let's be real what's the survival rate
for people under the age of from from
the ages of like like 11 to 20 or
whatever is like 99.999 percent
yes and i guess the argument is but
they'll spread it to grandma and it's
it's always just like well then
you know keep grandma safe i sleep
isolate use sanitizer and
why why you know i read this really
interesting blog post i remember it was
a while ago
and it was from an older person who said
i don't understand why you're asking the
younger generation to sacrifice their
lives for the older generation
the older generation typically sacrifice
their lives for the next generation
someone who's in their 80s like do you
guys remember what happened with uh
fukushima
the nuclear plant title tsunami hits it
radioactive waste and then the elderly
volunteered to go into the plant
to try and stop the leak and solve the
problem because they were like well
we're going to die soon anyway
we'll we we will sacrifice ourselves for
the youth i actually know somebody uh
luke and i knew somebody who was older
and
and lost her life providing tours to
journalists in the media top
get the word out and explain what was
going on in this area she ended up
getting cancer
and so with you know the utmost respect
she was an amazing individual
the older generation willing to risk
them you know their lives to help
the next generations survive this to me
is
is absolutely insane yeah making the
kids sacrifice their education their
well-being their upbringing their food
their nurturing
for the older generation look i don't
want anyone to die
and i think ultimately it's the choice
of the older generation i want to keep
them safe and protected i don't want to
force anybody to sacrifice anything
i just think it's interesting that we've
decided as a society that it's better to
sacrifice the kids
well-being for you know a 99-point
i believe for the people above 70. it's
a 99.5 percent survival right no i'm
sorry 97.5
survival rate i just think there's some
kind of imbalance there maybe we need to
address the harder questions about you
know how we deal with this
maybe we need to make sure that the
elderly are
protected i think maybe andrew cuomo
needed a lesson in that regard that he
never
uh got not just him but these other
governors as well
i don't know man i just i think these
kids you know when you look at the masks
you look at the schools there are kids
who are now spending a large portion of
their lives
over a year not seeing strangers faces
not seeing expressions not seeing mouths
move
when you look when you look at a
person's face you know you can tell
people can tell when when someone's
faking a smile
because a real smile your eyes actually
you know smile as well you smile with
your eyes
and when even when someone's wearing a
mask you can see when they're smiling
the way their eyes move
but what about a kid who doesn't know
and hasn't had the chance to develop
those social understanding
they're going to be socially stunted i
mean they're the most important
formative years and we're damaging these
kids over this stuff
stuffing them in these tents to play
music you know what man
if it were me i wouldn't even go to
these schools when i was 14
i was in i went to high school for about
two months and then i just one day was
walking to school stopped turned around
and went home and that was it
do you kind of want to hear what it
sounds like when they're playing in the
tents though
yes i do yeah i'm curious yeah i wish
there was
but you bring up an important point
first of all that fukushima trip was
insane i don't know why i went with you
but we did
um second of all it's hopefully we don't
get thyroid cancer yeah
um yeah so that gives me a little bit of
anxiety as well
thanks tim uh thanks for reminding me
what it's do i try not to think about
that but but when we talk about these
school children
you know a lot of them who do get the
chance to go back they're forced
to social distance they're forced to
mask but they're also
in some schools forced to wear tracking
beacons
that go off if they get too close to
other students
and they get in trouble and they get
punished by standing or walking too
close to other people
so that's the level of absurdity imagine
going to a school
and your developmental years are
authoritarians
screaming at you not to be close to
another human being
or in some instances like in buffalo
telling you that all white people
are racist you know just like the story
that we covered yesterday
that's why again i'm a big proponent of
homeschooling homeschooling networks
uh are something that people should look
into i know it's very difficult for
people to raise children independently
but there's networks out there
that let you do this in a way that's
very cost effective
that that's that saves you a lot of time
and also lets
you be a part of a community that
teaches your
children the values that you believe in
personally
rather than of course having a
government come in there and scare the
other
crap out of your children so i think
everybody here seems to be fairly on the
uh
not big fans of government scale i
suppose not
i don't want to say anarchist luke is
definitely the
resident government
stupidity like this they found covid in
an ice cream factory in china there's
news
that i don't know thousands of ice cream
tested positive for cover that it was
living in the fat cells and you're
saying that like the
greatest comorbidity is obesity where
there's a lot of fat cells
so that they're obsessed with the air
and transmitting it through the air when
there's evidence that it's in the food
is but completely driving me insane you
have to breathe it in though right no
you don't have to breathe you can eat it
too
you can get covered from eating it
apparently that's what was happening
with this why they were recalling all
this ice cream
weird well i thought i had not heard
that yeah
yeah which is odd you would well no the
media would be like red alert
no but ian's right because in china they
do the butt swabs yep it's in your
digestive tract you heard about that
right there's reports i did i didn't
read a proper report i saw him
probably don't want to right you know
but like the joke i made was
shut up and put on your mask otherwise
the butt swabs are next there's some
preliminary reports that us diplomats
were forced
to get those swabs up there you know
what no
i i haven't seen it they're confirmed i
haven't seen it confirmed but i'm seeing
some reports
right now you said you know what are you
saying but or who
no no no they're they're butt taxes oh
okay yeah they're
you know so so there's reports of us
diplomats being forced
to do this uh haven't been confirmed yet
so we're looking up i'm i'm trying to
verify this as we're speaking right now
americans being forced to do it i
wouldn't be surprised the gateway pundit
reported on it now
how are you i'm i'm checking out the
sources how are you handling family life
through covet you got kids you said
earlier i have kids um
you know the in the beginning we didn't
know what was happening
and it was real scary and we didn't
leave my house
and they i have two kids in college on
the east coast they came home
uh and we just kind of hunkered down and
and then we figured out how to live you
know i think
you know as a person who doesn't do
well with the imposition of somebody
else's rules
i also look around and recognize that
there have always been rules
and the happiest i ever feel is when i'm
just trying to
succeed despite them if that makes sense
yeah yeah so like it's not everything's
not the way i want it to be but it's
kind of just like a new game to navigate
that's that's i think that's one of the
smartest ways to look at it too you know
that one of the ways i've always treated
is
i'm not super concerned i'm definitely
concerned when we see the rise of
authoritarianism
i know i can survive it i know that you
know i'm clever enough to find my way
through the new rules to make things
work and all that stuff
i do worry about other people i also
worry about the principles of the matter
you know
people have a right people have rights
to be free to speak their minds
and so there are there are definitely
problems in that regard we have to have
us
we have to have like a baseline of when
we go too far to not allow something
like that you know what i mean
yeah no totally i don't know i think
the way i try to think about it is
the way i want it to be it's not always
going to be the way i want it to be
it's never been exactly the way i want
it to be but that's fine
um i try to give people the benefit of
the doubt and go like
i i believe people are basically good
and that the intention is safety
you know maybe not for raytheon i don't
know
i don't know if that's their intention
that's kind of the opposite
for the most part i think you have
but i think you could look back through
history and pick
any of the things we call atrocities
that
are atrocities and go somebody had
in the beginning the intention to keep
some group of people safe
well look at uh what was it tnt dynamite
or those are different i think
but uh you alfred nobel right he
invented it
and what happened was i could be messing
the story up i guess the intention was
to help
mining you basically instead of having
people get trapped and just do you put
the bombs there and you walk away and
then kaboom and then there you go it's
been done
and then people we were using as a
weapon and so one day
some newspaper accidentally published
his obituary while he was still alive
and they called him the merchant of
death oh
and so he saw that was like is that my
legacy so then
nobel prize was created because he
wanted to do something better
because he didn't want to be the really
you know awful
nobel prize is quite a swan song yeah
yeah
but it's like uh you know whatever your
intention is for your creation
it can go in a wrong direction right no
totally i i think
but i think about that too like the
things that i would be most critical of
with uh government i try to give them
the benefit of the doubt and go
somebody is is has a concern
and they're trying you know i don't know
that that's always true right
it's hard to say that uh but even like
you know our economy crashes and burns
if we don't enforce the petro dollar
let's
right right right right a lot of people
don't understand this you know no this
is a really good point cause people are
talking big right now about
joe biden bombing syria it's big news we
did talk about a little bit
and i tell people you realize that when
the u.s is going to war
in the middle eastern countries it's not
you know you'll hear
a lot of lefting activists say americans
just want to blow up kids and stuff like
that i'll joke and say something like
that like you know
oh who else is going to do it america
loves doing it the reality is
these special interests want money and
resources
they want to build the cutter turkey
pipeline to deliver cheap gas into
europe to dominate the market make money
but also offset the prices for the
people who live there
it's it's for them it's like hey it's a
win-win we get rich they're not doing it
because they're mustache twirling
villains we're like
let's blop a country they're they're
they're saying i want something that's
going to benefit
my team yeah and they're willing to do
horrifying things to do it
and i look at that i'm like i am not
interested in funding you
blowing up and destroying a country so
you can get cheap gas
into into europe man i'm not in favor of
that yeah i i
listen morally i'm not in favor of it
either but
when we think about stuff like health
care and and your proponent for
universal health care that's not
possible
idealistically i am but right you know
not possible
if we get rid of if if we say hey we're
pulling out of the middle east
right our economy crumbles it implodes
it's done so all of these plans that are
being argued about in america
are kind of like you know none of it
survives without those wars
well in terms of getting the oil you
know in a lot of these countries but
we're also producing what
poppy and opium in afghanistan so
there's like it's it's about control
and a lot of things i'm not entirely
convinced though i think one of the big
arguments we saw through the trump years
was
how about we focus on energy development
in this country
that way we're not reliant on that and
we became energy independent so we
didn't need those wars anymore and then
we got the abraham accords these are
things that i think are good
and i i before aoc came out with it i
was a huge proponent of the green new
deal
i made i made a couple different
segments where i was like i like this
you know why
before they actually put the bill out it
was like
would you like to invest government
resources and taxpayer dollars into
advancing green technologies to make the
united states more
environmentally friendly and energy
independent and i was like that sounds
like the coolest thing ever
and then they actually release the green
new deal and it's like would you like
social equity to give
you know women of color access to
college and healthcare and i'm like look
i appreciate the attempt to help people
but please don't use
my ideals for environmentalism to push
your critical race theory
because i'm not a fan of that and the
green new deal became about changing the
economy and not about developing this
technology
so it was like a slap in the face the
people who actually thought we got a
good thing going
and then the people who are supposed to
be proponents of this environmental
technology
like i seriously the second page of the
bill was was all critical race
theory social justice had nothing to do
with the environment we're going to
provide college and health care and i'm
like wait wait wait what
i thought we were going to build a
fusion reactor reach ignition man
and then we're going to have flying cars
is there anybody trying to do that
they're doing fusion there's a lot of
people working on it
jpl is working on it yeah but we've not
minor sayings we haven't reached the
ignition phase is that what is where
i think not where the fusion happens and
then the reaction outputs more energy
that's put in so
like you know ignition like a fire well
another thing to really kind of consider
here is that um the us dollar is going
to collapse inevitably
especially with its monty money printing
especially with its money supply
and there's some people arguing that if
we end the wars in the middle east
and this reckless spending that the debt
wouldn't be as high
and we we would postpone this inevitable
collapse because we are already
indebted to such a way where it's
impossible to pay back
and uh this is something that of course
is going to fall in on itself eventually
okay but i have a question
we're able to rack up so much debt
because the trading of oil
is predominantly done with us dollars
around the world yes
so that offsets our ability to incur
debt
yep if we pull out we can incur
no more debt right and all the debt that
we've incurred
collapses on us it's so it's not even
necessarily about
getting the oil it's just about saying
you must use dollars
this is a system put in by henry
kissinger when of course he went over to
saudi arabia and this is the larger deal
that they have now
but we saw trump kind of throw a wrench
into a little bit
one he was brutally honest he was like
yeah we're in syria we're stealing their
oil
yes we're giving saudi arabia the
weapons because we want money they pay
us a good deal
but also he also had a big priority on
energy where america became the number
one
energy producer in the world uh when
donald trump was in power
so yes it's it's pretty pretty much run
through the military industrial complex
but when you look at the larger kind of
foreign policy
mishaps not just the chaos but the money
spent
they don't serve any purpose and in the
long run in my opinion they're going to
be hurting the united states because
they could enforce
the trading of you know oil on the
dollar in many different ways but
entangling ourselves in afghanistan and
spending so much money there
recklessly and and just wasting it away
is not going to
to ensure that but but ethan hit the
nail on the head yeah
we can rack up as much debt as we want
so long as we force everyone to buy oil
with our dollars
yeah so so i have this but that's kind
of like i want to say
no war morally i go this war
doesn't make sense to me yeah morally
but i recognize at the same time
what happens here if we're not doing
that this is this is a really good point
man
i'd have no problem living in the woods
you know we
there's this joke i will not live in the
pot i will not eat the bugs and i'm like
well hold on
i'll live in the pot not like the bugs
you know why because my pod is going to
be up in a tree
right next to a nice little river where
i'll go fishing and periodically eat
bugs
i got no problem if i had to live in the
wilderness
and learn to survive and and actually
work hard
to survive i actually respect that and i
would enjoy it
i i i love being out and walking through
the woods and uh i love
that feeling of accomplishment in these
things it's it's cool till you cut
yourself
sure we'll have to learn how to make
alcohol and all this stuff but here's
the point
it's really easy to say you know what
fine
no war let the petro dollar fail and
then so what what's the worst is going
to happen americans are going to have to
learn to survive again
that's not the worst that'll happen well
i'm wondering no no no no the worst
that'll happen is that china will take
over
and then within the matter of time you
living in the woods thinking about your
own business will eventually be under a
global authority of chinese
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you